how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
relating to marvel and of course the
marvel cinematic universe
and today we have some phase 5 news
specifically revolving around blade
and moon knight a new character is going
to be coming to the mcu that could
connect the two
and depending on what marvel and sony
have worked out with each other for
the spider-man universe that they share
with each other we could even see this
character pop
up in a morbius venom or spider-man film
we could even have a whole monster
universe coming to the marvel cinematic
universe characters like morbius
blade who hunts down monsters and
vampires dracula
moon knight and many other awesome ones
so we'll break down this new report of
this new character
coming to phase 5 and talk about what it
means but first congratulations to
youtube user rocket
rat for being last week's winner of the
iron man funko pop giveaway
this week we're giving away a captain
america funko pop from avengers in game
same rules all you have to do is
subscribe like the video
leave a comment about the video down
below so today's report comes from
casey walsh from the website the geeks
worldwide
and him and some other previous people
not too long ago have said that they
have seen
elsa bloodstone's name included with
those of blade
and moon knight now if you are unaware
of who elsa bloodstone is she is the
daughter of
ulysses bloodstone and she's an expert
monster hunter she has many different
powers including superhuman strength
speed stamina agility she also has the
ability to heal herself
she's an expert marksman and she has the
use of mystic
powers now what makes this very
interesting about her joining the mcu is
the report that we are getting a
rider in the mcu as well and the reason
this is interesting is because it looks
like marvel could be planning to
introduce
the midnight suns this was a group put
together in the comics by ghost writer
and doctor strange they were formed to
fight
different kinds of threats more mystic
demonic
monster type of threats and if marvel
does decide to do this group it seems
like we already know who they're going
to put in the group
doctor strange of course moon knight
blade
morbius and now of course elsa
bloodstone
now this could be a pretty incredible
group of people in the marvel cinematic
universe and we do know based off of
everything that we've heard so far that
marvel is going to explore the more
mystic side of the universe and this is
all going to start with
wanda vision we've seen the leaked
photos of the salem witch trials
implying that the more
mystic side is going to be in that show
and of course we know that this is going
to tie into
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness in which he himself is the
master of the mystic
arts we already have morbius coming out
and we've already seen that it is tied
to the mcu in some way or form and then
of course
we have blade and moon knight both have
officially been announced by marvel
studios
and now with the report that elsa
bloodstone has been attached
to blade and moon knight it appears that
the plan for marvel
eventually would be to unite all of
these characters and form the sons of
midnight
we know that doctor strange is going to
have a lot on his plate during
multiverse of madness
and it might be safe to assume that he
won't be able to contain
everything that's going to happen and
perhaps there's a demon of some sort
maybe even mafesto that gets out that he
can't contain or even multiple demons
that come from other realities and go
into the main reality
so what would he do call upon the sons
of midnight
and it really would be a perfect
opportunity to connect
all of those characters together blade
morbius
moon knight elsa bloodstone and the one
and only ghost rider
it seems like this is the path that
marvel's going down and not to mention
once upon a time
abc almost did a series about elsa
bloodstone with marvel
seems like they've had plans for her for
a while and now she's going to be
entering the mcu under kevin feige's
control
so let me know what you think about elsa
bloodstone and
the sons of midnight possibly coming to
the mcu be sure to let me know what you
think in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof